Happy Thanksgiving ladies and gentlemen.
It's a time of year we all gather round and  we say thanks for the things we're thankful for.
Yeah, I'm thankful for friends.
I'm thankful for you Carmichael.
I have to put an asterisk there.
Friends and Carmichael. *awwww*
Two different things
So I always ask the question
What would you like to do if money were no object?
What would, how would you really enjoy spending your life?
I am thankful for my awesome family.
Awesome group of friends.
Awesome group of dudes
who are also my friends that I get to work with every day.
And I'm thankful for you guys.
Being able to let me do this awesome job,
Happy Thanksgiving
Cmike: Is that really all?
:ı
IS THAT REALLY ALL?!
Well. It's so amazing as a result of our kind of educational system,
crowds of students say:
Well,
We'd like to be painters. We'd like to be poets.
We'd like to be writers, but as everybody knows you can't earn any money that way.
You know what I'm thankful for?
Fan art, free video ideas that people email us.
If you get to the point
Where you making videos and people email you their ideas, and they're like:
Hey!
You know I was just thinking about this the other day.
Here's my idea.
That is a very special place to be...
I'll always hold those in my heart. Even if I don't respond.
No, seriously though.
Thank you.
When we finally got down to something,
which the individual says he really wants to do,
I will say to him:
You do that.
and...
Forget the money
ah..
Because
If you say that, getting the money is the most important thing,
You will spend your life,
completely wasting your time
You'll be doing things you don't like doing in order to go on living that is to go on doing things
you don't like doing.
which is stupid!
I'm thankful...
Has anyone think to the audience yet?
I assume everyone's going to be thanking them.
Cuz that's why we're here.
I mean, that's not why we're here.
I mean, if you wanna look at the grand picture,
like:
You can go one step up
We're here because our parents fell in love
NO! OK
Way too many right now.
I'm saying why we're here as a company
because we would have floundered years ago.
If there weren't anyone here to watch our stuff
Thank you for being patient with us as we... stumble through how to figure out-
How to do any of this.
It's really cool. It's ah...
Thank you for saying "Hi" to me.
If you ever see me in person, that's really cool.
I'm thankful for the community that you all have fostered on both reddit in the comments on YouTube
I'm thankful that you have provided me with a sort of career that I never would have ever
anticipated?
Better to have a short life that is full of what you like doing than a long life spent in a miserable way.
And after all,
If you do really like what you're doing it doesn't matter what it is
You can eventually turn it -
You will eventually become a master of it.
The only way to become a master of something, to be really with it.
And then you'll be able to get a good fee for whatever it is.
And anything you could be interested in you will find as well.
But it's absolutely stupid spend your time doing things you don't like,
in order to go on spending things you don't like
and doing things you don't like
and to teach your children to follow in the same track.
Oh, I don't know. I had a special year.
Oh, how do I put it? Well I mean-
I'm just generally thankful that Sarah and myself moved into our first home together this year.
And also having a baby boy, which is pretty crazy to say.
But what I'm thankful for about it is that-
so far everything's gone so well.
and-
I know that's not the case for-
For everyone sometimes you know people have problems in life,
and the problems suck when you have them.
I've had a very smooth year, especially a smooth year.
Coinciding with huge life events happening
is-
something definitely to be thankful for.
That's like this super serious answer, and I-
It's all about me
I guess so, but that's what I'm thinking. I've that's what I'm thankful
That's what I'm thankful for
I'm thankful for having such a huge year also having a very smooth year.
Because, when people have huge-
life changes like the ones I'm in-
-encountering right now.
Just just having everything be nice and smooth like,
It means everything right now.
The moment you have a situation
Where you are really in control of things that is to say in which the future is
almost completely predictable.
A completely predictable future is already the past.
You've had it.
That's not what you want.
You want a surprise.
You don't know what that's gonna be because obviously it wouldn't be a surprise if you did.
I'm thankful for all of you watching our videos
enjoying these adventures we go on,
learning with us, growing with us and letting us entertain you on this channel.
I'm also super thankful,
for this wonderful team we have around us.
If you guys have been around since the beginning of corridor digital;
That's just a couple of us doing these things weird kooky videos online
But now it's blown up into a whole group of-
friends and colleagues and co-workers and the artists who are working together to do some really cool stuff.
And that's with all of your support
So I'm thankful for all these guys including this guy behind the camera and they glow for you for watching
What are you thankful for Carmichael?
*Cmike doing making weird sounds, trying to escape*
CLICK THE GDAMN SUBSCRIBE BUTTON.
AND THE LIKE BUTTON AND HAVE A GREAT THANKSGIVING
SUBTITLE EDITOR DUDE